OBAMA.
EXTREMELY UNUSUAL ONSLAUGHT
AMONG PUBLIC ALLIES.
BARBARA STARR, WALK US THROUGH
WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
>> WE DO WANT TO START BY
WARNING EVERYONE THE LANGUAGE BY
THE PHILIPPINE LEADER IS
GRAPHIC.
HE ISSUED A DIRECT CHALLENGE TO
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND PRESIDENT
OBAMA NOT TAKING KINDLY TO ANY
OF IT.
>> WHO IS HE?
>> PHILIPPINE PRESIDENT AMPING
UP HIS VULGAR LANGUAGE, URGING
PRESIDENT OBAMA TO NOT BRING UP
THE ALLEGED KILLED SUSPECT
DURING PLANNED MEETING OF
SOUTHEAST ASIAN LEADERS IN
LOUSE.
>> I'M A PRESIDENT AFTER
SOVEREIGN STATE.
AND WE HAVE LONG CEASED TO BE A
COLONY.
>> DUETERTE WARNING ANYONE WHO
ASKED HIM ABOUT THE KILLINGS
SOME 2,000 SINCE MAY.
>> YOU MUST BE RESPECTFUL.
>> SWITCHING TO NATIVE LANGUAGE
TO MAKE HIS POSITION EVEN MORE
CLEAR.
>> Translator: SON OF A BITCH,
I'LL CURSE YOU IN FRONT OF
EVERYBODY.
>> NOW, THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS
PRESIDENT OBAMA WILL NOT MEET
WITH DUETERTE, BUT IF IT WERE TO
HAPPEN, HE PLANS TO PUSH FOR DUE
PROCESS.
>> IF AND WHEN WE HAVE A
MEETING, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WILL BE BROUGHT UP.
>> DUTERTE'S HARD LINE WARD ON
DRUGS WAS PART OF HIS CAMPAIGN
EARLIER THIS YEAR.
HIS COMMENTS ABOUT PRESIDENT
OBAMA JUST THE LATEST U.S.
CONCERN.
IN ANOTHER COURSE VERBAL
ASSAULT, DUERTETE CALLED PHILLIP
A HOMOPHOBIC SLUR.
>> I WAS ANGRY SHE WAS RAPED.
YES, THAT WAS ONE THING.
BUT SHE WAS SO BEAUTIFUL.
I THINK THE MAYOR SHOULD HAVE
BEEN FIRST.
>> STATEMENTS BY ANYONE ANYWHERE
THAT EITHER DEGRADE WOMEN OR
TRIVIALIZE ISSUES SO SERIOUS AS
RAPE FOR MURDER ARE NOT ONES
THAT WE CONDONE.
>> NOW THERE STILL MAY BE
SOMETHING THAT DUERTEE WANT FROM
THE SUITES.
CHINA IS MILITARIZING THE SOUTH
CHINA SEA OFF OF COAST OF THE
PHILIPPINES AND HE MAY HAVE THE
NEED, EXPERTS WILL TELL YOU,